avec mes jeunes amis de sarcelles les
chanteurs de luca tao je vais vous
chanter une autre nouvelle chanson une
chanson qui s'appelle c'est ça la france
[Musique]
là
je
[Musique]
et ça
avis au coeur
ça
à
[Musique]
ouais
c'est
monsieur
m
il a
[Musique]
qui paie
ap
le vase pour boisset au port d'une école
en choeur
[Musique]
les temps
dans un vaisseau les escargots comment
les toits
à
la gate ou chinois
hahaha
[Musique]
c'est ça
et
[Musique]
à
son cas
sa dette
c'est non
[Musique]
ayrault
oui mais
eh oui
p j'en ai
[Musique]
un petit mâle qui tourne en hachant
temps
charlemagne et le
[Musique]
oui
mais où
tous deux mois oh
[Musique]
non
c'est ça
[Musique]
et on chantait
m
à
non
mais le champ
dans mon coeur
[Musique]
il
il est
simon
ok
m jean
[Musique]